In the last lesson, lesson 4. We learned
that lactose intolerance is caused by the absence of
an enzyme called lactase. And this trait is
otherwise known as lactase non persistence. So, if you
show signs of lactose intolerance, it's because you
don't have enough lactase around to digest the lactose.
Because you're lactase non persistent. You don't express
lactase anymore. But if you can digest lactose product,
you're lactose tolerant because you still have lactase
around. You had lactase persistence. You still express
the lactase enzyme. Now there were 2 particular
alleles that we discussed at the link, and they
are both located about 13,000 base pair upstream
of the transcription initiation side at the lactase coding
region. A Cytosine or C, up here in
the enhancer region, correlates with lactase non persistence or
symptoms of lactose intolerance like Kate has, the
other allele a Thymine or T in enhancer
region, correlates with lactase persistence, meaning that we
will have lactase around and we can digest
lactose so, we'll be lactose tolerant. So based
on this information, how many different allelic combinations
are even possible? And remember as a hint,
every human has two alleles for the lactase gene.
Go ahead and put the answer you think in this text box here.